dude honestly
after peep died i was still on drugs so
i'm not going to lie because you were
really close with people yeah we don't
know yeah we got a tour together like
from the beginning everything but i
think once after he died i was still on
drugs but
like maybe like a year and some change
after i was like oh [ __ ] like bro died
people are dying like
realistically i can't be on drugs my
whole life like one day you're gonna
quit or you're gonna die and that's it
like you have to quit one day yeah so
i'm like why not quit now while i'm
younger rather than waiting digging
myself deeper and quitting later hmm was
it how hard was it man it was bad
withdrawals and all that my mental
withdrawals were worth in my physical
withdrawals because my physical
withdrawals lasted like what maybe like
a little over a month you know like
puking when i [ __ ] yourself you can't
eat you can't sleep you sweat you can't
do this but the mental lasted yeah me
and i still think like my shit's wired
different
not in a bad way just when you say
mentally what do you mean like
like just like thoughts or like your
anxiety or like your depression states
or just like overthinking just all that
[ __ ] you get me like it just like
scrambled now my show's already
scrambled my she's like
[ __ ] yeah like what what at the time
like let's say your peak drug use what
all were you putting into your body man
dude honestly i was probably drinking
maybe like
a four a day which i don't think is [ __ ]
like i think we lean is the weakest
opiate
but then i was taking like maybe like
four to six or four to five blues a day
wow